the Joe Rogan experience forever yeah
I'm 51 a-ha started training when I was
really seriously when I was 15
oh [ __ ] yeah damn suck what the [ __ ] was
that doing yeah will you wrap it when
you're 15 Wow when did you first get in
this - that's one thing I really admire
about a lot of rappers guys are always
working yeah
rappers are always in the studio
hopefully that's like a big thing you
know it's like there's a discipline
aspect to it that I don't think that
gets appreciated yeah yeah you have to
be you're always in the lab you're
always working constantly it's like
training you gotta be you gotta work at
it it's competitive yeah yeah you got to
be in a studio not work for producers
you got to become a new [ __ ] knowing
who's next and who's then like working
with them and [ __ ] like that so like at
the end of the day yeah it's a crap [ __ ]
I've been in the studio since I was like
14 15 and there was times when my dad
used to have to tell me like you know
get out of the studio like go play with
your friend be a kid be normal like I'm
saying like there was times that [ __ ]
happen and even now like I don't really
do normal [ __ ] you know and I mean I
might like go to the movies or like go
to Dave & Buster's or something like
that but like I don't do [ __ ] like I
just go to the studio
much rather just you know what I mean
yeah create well that's amazing that you
figured it out so young how old were you
when you knew you wanted to be a rapper
oh I think I was in third grade
real [ __ ] I think I was a third grade
that's amazing to be a ninja turtle and
I wanted to be a rapper I think a rapper
was like a little bit more realistic I'm
working on being a ninja turtle now
that's amazing thing great it they're
great holds you in third grade again do
you nine you know yeah yeah yeah that's
when I started writing my first rats and
[ __ ] is hilarious
yeah I was like watching music videos
and I remember seeing like puffy
biggie and bond with Thugs and harmony
is like one of my favorite groups Wow so
like yo if I could do that I'll be
alright and then by the time I was like
that's when the internet was really
popular so you could download like
instrumentals and [ __ ] like that so you
didn't have to like have beats or
anything mmm then they started
introducing you know at home equipment
they have like a little tascam for track
little [ __ ] thing that you could
hear me so i started [ __ ] around on
that mic doing my own little home studio
then fruityloops came out started making
beats Cool Edit Pro was like the the
program back then before Pro Tools and
yeah that's how I got my start like just
in the [ __ ] in the in the create just
putting it together then I turn like
then about the time I was like 16 I got
like an internship at a UH at a studio
in Pittsburgh where I was literally like
answering the phones and running errands
going to pick up like office supplies
and [ __ ] like that and in return they
would pay me with studio time so like I
would just record like off you know me
off the clock you mean like four or five
songs and that turned into the record
dude Wow yep got my first deal at 16
that's an amazing story is wow that's
that's a movie story that's crazy you
always knew yeah yeah it was something
that I worked out for sure because it
was like being him in Pittsburgh you're
been a big part yeah you know it's
pretty crazy out there right crazy how
like it's just a really wild city like
the Midwest so it's like there's either
a couple things you can do and there's
not a lot and working the job is like
the last thing that anybody wants to do
in Pittsburgh so all my cousins and
everybody that I know do different [ __ ]
than what I was willing to do I was like
you know I'm not trying to be that guy
like like that so I was like how am I
gonna make away from myself you know
enemy out of [ __ ] am I gonna get still
be fresh still you know me enjoy myself
have a good time we'll be safe and like
have fun it was music so it's amazing
you nailed it yes and nailed it young
yeah that's a beautiful thing to know
what you want to do new and just be
working towards it have
many people that's the real problem the
real problem is like finding a thing did
you know find anything they really love
so much to me all their energy into yeah
I mean I'm blessed to grow up in a time
to where technology was like taking over
and [ __ ] and I think like if you're my
age and you like make music or got a
camera or you're not I mean anything
around that you could like and now I
think it's like if you have anything to
do a we'd like do not grow it if you
could sell it if you could brand it if
you come up with light technology or
whatever it is like that's gonna be the
future for this generation there's like
pot
[Applause]